évidemment le françois cluzet emporté
engagé qui ne mâche pas ses mots qui a
son franc parler bien sûr vous vous en
êtes fait quelques-uns de lucchini ah ah
oui vous mais c'est parce que c'est des
cons c'est des congés rien d'autre à
dire sont des cons sont des cons ce sont
des voix là vous voyez je mâche pas mes
mots encore ni sont les comptes je vous
dis ça m'arrive d'être con hein et ça
m'est arrivé peut-être plusieurs plus
plus de fois qu aux autres mais reste on
est con parce que il saute sur
l'occasion de la pandémie l'un pour dire
mais l'autre il le restaurateur il avait
les couteaux mais ferme ta gueule et
bien prêt ou pas mais je regrette pas je
le pense ouvertement ce sont des mégalos
et l'autre abruti deux premiers qui se
présente président de la république en
disant allez tous vous faire mais ça va
pas la tête non mais viennent d'où ces
mecs là ils ont un ego comme un gratte
ciel qui nous foutent la paix on est
suffisamment dans la merde qui nous
donne de l'espoir il n'a pas qui donne
de l'espoir sont tous là à dire
d'étudier des mets ta gueule ferme-la et
puis donne ce que tu as à donner ne
vient pas nous donner tes tête au prurit
cérébrale mais qui nie bigard c'est vrai
merde on est des acteurs on est au
service du public et on est là pour leur
apprendre la joie et leur offrir quelque
chose on n'est pas là pour se montrer en
dix ans mais le gouvernement mais c'est
tellement sont fous écrase soins le
gouvernement tiller au gouvernement tu
la veux la place donc ça m'insupporte
mais maintenant qu'ils ont le sourire
numéro je fais un peu mon numéro pour
vous dire que je suis vif avec les
mégalos parce qu'en plus ces gens là ne
donne pas une bonne idée de nous autres
interprètes ont de dieu nous sommes des
interprètes nous ne sommes pas seuls en
scène nous sommes des partenaires aucun
des deux n'est un partenaire il ne donne
rien à l'autre je le sais j'ai joué avec
eux il ne donne rien donc s'ils ne
donnent rien aux partenaires ya rien
résultat des courses le public n'a rien
pourquoi parce que ce sont des
égocentriques nombrilique mégalo je ne
sais pas quoi mais franchement il donne
une image de ce métier
épouvantable alors que moi la chance que
j'ai c'est que je connais les grands
artistes du théâtre et du cinéma je les
connais je les fréquente et j'essaye
d'apporter mon tout petit pierre à
l'édifice donc le film soit réussie et
non pas montrer ma gueule en disant vous
avez vu vous avez vu vous a eu et puis
avec ces déversements de cérébral
d'intellectualisme et de lectures et de
lectures et de lectures et de lectures
et de lecture ou en boîte en boîte et
alors tu as lu tous les bouquins du
monde et ça ne t'a pas donné l'humanité
ça ne t'a pas donné la générosité ballon
tu aurais mieux fait de ne pas les lire
françois cluzet cette vérité cette
colère on l'entend et le public vous
aime beaucoup pour ça mais non juste ce
franc parler dont je m'excuse de
m'énerver parce que je vous le dis c'est
un peu un numéro d'acteur donc je suis
franc genre tout entier tous mais je ne
supporte pas les gens qui ne donne rien
et qui reçoit beaucoup